okay well the pilot is insane and it's
it's it's what it's SWAT Unleashed you
know did some people is not a remake
okay it is not a remake so those of us
are old enough to remember the 70s TV
show I'm old enough but I remember and I
was running around acting like a SWAT
guy but but I remember the theme song no
no no no when you hear that theme song
it just it just gets you excited all
over again but it's not a remake of the
70s show it's not a remake of the movie
15 years ago but kudos to Michelle
Rodriguez LL Cool J Colin Farrell and
then the last person to play Hondo was
Sam Jackson Samuel Jackson and so I'm
not about to try to imitate what he did
he's the man I'm going to give my own
version but this is SWAT 2017 in real
life today what's going on today so it
is a thrill ride it's going to entertain
you like nobody's business the action is
crazy Justin Lin you know always
imitated never duplicated the man and he
knows action and then Sean Ryan who's
executive produce show run the unit the
shield he's handling SWAT so the man can
write and then myself my supporting cast
we're going to give you the same
characters same name bringing back the
theme song though you know not and on
and on we're going to give you all that
with some stank I'd like to say but
we're going to surprise you we're going
to it you're going to be screaming at
the TV like yeah go go go but then you
can be like whoa wait a minute what did
I just watch that's crazy they went
there oh they're going there with it
because it's going to because I don't
care who you are I don't care how old
you are I don't care what ethnicity you
are you may not relate to everything you
may not agree with everything but you're
going to recognize like this is powerful
this is powerful this is fun but there's
a powerful message in there based on
what's going on in this country and and
around the world
I want to ask you what what makes you
more nervous doing the stuff or the love
scene I would have to say I would what
makes me more nervous the stunts or love
scenes I guess it would be the love
scenes in the sense of stunts are just
your soaks I mean I'm excited to do both
I'm not tripping I mean I'm not crazy
like you get a pretty girl opposite use
like are you know pretty good gig I got
um you know the stunts are just fun you
know the only thing you worry about with
the sun's you don't want to get hurt and
you want to do them right but we've got
we've got
popper training we've got the best of
the best in the stunt business we've got
the best of the best and the real deal
ease which is really important for
people to realize is that we're not just
actors running around with guns we've
got LAPD SWAT we've got San Diego PD
SWAT we've got SEAL Team six these are
these are the real men and women that
are really really out there you know
fighting for justice and deal with the
dark side deal with the dark dark side
and still find a way to fight for the
fight for the light fight for help fight
for fight for compassion and justice as
far as love scenes you know they're you
know they once they're all edited
together and hope you know you get you I
got the pretty girl opposite knee
I mean angle I that's that's pretty
that's pretty cool you know you're paid
for this but it's really technical it's
really technical so you might be happy
naked what I like to say rolling around
playing kissy-face but you understand
there's like 4050 people stand around
staring at you you know and then you and
everything's for camera so it's real
technical to do it but you know I mean
it's uh I don't wake up I don't wake up
nervous I'd I wake up and go okay well
you know what this is one day that I
hope doesn't end too soon crazy world
that there will be a crossover between
Criminal Minds and slots that's that's
it I've been asked this question lately
I just is there a way that SWAT and
Criminal Minds could cross over I just
don't know how like I mean you got Derek
Morgan with the goatee
now you got hondo with that I don't know
what you call this that I created I I've
always told I want I want my Criminal
Minds fans and my young and restaurants
from way back in a day
none of those doors closed in my mind
okay Malcolm winters is not dead Derrick
Morgan is not dead I told the Criminal
Minds fans those elevator doors closed
but they can always open up again but
I'm so excited and I'm so invested I'm
so focused on bringing the SWAT to life
because I know it's like I really
believe it's going to be a TV
game-changing it's just going to
surprise people and I think people
people are going to watch it be excited
and can't wait for next week but I don't
know how if I was once Derek but now I'm
Hondo so if those two worlds collide
then what am i bipolar do I need
medication like how does that work I
don't know so it doesn't it doesn't seem
like it's feasible but is there a way
for me to do one or the other I'll never
say no to that
because I without without Malcolm
winters which led to Derrick Morgan
there would be no Daniel Hondo arrows